on the week marking the 50th anniversary
of Woodstock Hollywood is remembering an
actor who rose to fame in that same year
Peter Fonda may be best remembered for
his role in the 1969 counterculture
classic Easy Rider but his acting career
endured for decades he died Friday of
complications from lung cancer he was 79
years old Easy Rider
was 260 cinema what Woodstock was to
that generations music the
counterculture classic about two bikers
on a drug-fueled road trip through the
southwest start Peter Fonda also earned
an Oscar nomination for co-writing the
film do your own thing in your own time
he should be Brad before he climbed on
that red white and blue motorbike Fonda
was already well-known he was the son of
a screen legend Henry Fonda and the
brother of actress Jane Fonda and now
you want me to kiss you so you can
compare his first film role team in 1963
starring alongside Sandra Dee Tammy and
the doctor like many in his generation
Fonda began to reject the establishment
throwing his hair long experimenting
with drugs during an acid trip with The
Beatles Fonda recalled a childhood
incident when he accidentally shot
himself he told John Lennon quote I know
what it's like to be dead Lennon used
that line in the Beatles song she said
she said
[Music]
[Applause]
I
Fonda would earn an acting Oscar
nomination decades later for ulee's gold
he would perform wearing the same I
glasses his father of war in his
oscar-winning role in 1980s on Golden
Pond in a statement his sister Jane said
of her brother I am very sad he was my
sweetheart at baby brother the talker of
the family I've had a beautiful alone
time with in these last days he went out
interesting sidenote here actually so
Dennis Hopper and Peter Fonda had to be
convinced to put Jack Nicholson in Easy
Rider right and then later on when Peter
Fonda was up against Jack Nicholson for
Best Actor Uli's gold for Fonda and as
good as it gets for Nicholson Nicholson
won that Oscar so interesting I love
what is this I love what Jane fun yeah
that's really really sweet
yeah and that he's the talker of the
family yeah and they got to spend the
final days together phenomen yeah